joe biden because he had to get to bed
he was probably already in bed before
but he got out
last night about i don't know what was
it about our time maybe
11 o'clock or earlier even joe biden
comes on stage
very positive very hopeful and
to my mind a little too confident we
feel good about where we are
we really do
[Applause]
i'm here to tell you tonight we believe
we're on track to win this election
we knew because of the unprecedented
early vote in the mail-in vote
that's going to take a while we're going
to have to be patient
until we uh the hard work of tallying
the votes is finished
and it ain't over until every vote is
counted every ballot is counted
[Applause]
but we're feeling good we're feeling
good about where we are
by the way that's that's not true what
he just said well i'm sure he is feeling
good and i think he's got a lot of
reason to feel good
for instance the attorney general of
pennsylvania promised him that he would
win the state
before election day promised it to him
isn't that autumn a man who is going to
be involved
in some of the litigation surrounding
pennsylvania
an elected official in that state
promising him
that state joe biden said that it's not
over until all the votes are counted
that may end up being true but that
ought not to be true according to the
rules
because what if i vote after election
day what if i vote two days after
election day what if i vote in december
christmas eve i decide you know i think
i'm going to vote for trump today
is that vote going to be counted no you
have to vote on time
but unfortunately the supreme court blew
up
those sorts of deadlines and now even
worse than that we're in a situation
where in pennsylvania
the votes may not even have to be
postmarked
there's a world in which they could just
find
i don't know ten thousand votes that's
pretty slim margins in these places
ten thousand twenty thousand thirty
thousand votes if the postmark is
smudged if it's unclear what the
postmark is
they could just count those votes we
know that there have been irregular
elections before this happened notably
a number of years ago with al franken
before he got booted out of the senate
but
when he was brought into the senate all
it looked like the republicans were
winning on election night
then all of a sudden a couple hundred
thousand mail-in votes just show up
they go overwhelmingly implausibly
some pundits have suggested
statistically impossibly
for the democrat and then the democrat
wins the race and republicans rolled
over
in that case joe biden seemed very
very confident president trump seemed
less confident when he walked in
to give his speech he didn't seem happy
now by the way
joe biden gave a speech much earlier
than than
donald trump did president trump walks
in and gave a speech at 2 30 in the
morning
this is a 74 year old man who had
coronavirus what two weeks ago
and and he came in and he gave his
speech
and he he said as he predicted as we
predicted on this show
this is going to the courts and did i
predict this
newt did i say this i've been saying
this from the day i heard
they were going to send out tens of
millions of ballots i said exactly
because either they were going to win or
if they didn't win
they'll take us to court for the good of
this nation this is a very big moment
this is a major fraud in our nation
we want the law to be used in a proper
manner
so we'll be going to the u.s supreme
court
we want all voting to stop
we don't want them to find any ballots
at
four o'clock in the morning and add them
to the list okay
it's it's a very sad it's a very sad
moment to me this is a very sad moment
and
we will win this and we as far as i'm
concerned we already have one
so i just want to thank you
there it is there is the line that's
that's getting president trump in
trouble
i want to go through because there are
people who are attacking him for this
even on the right we had a little
disagreement on the
daily wire set last night about about
what to make of this statement there are
a couple statements in here that are
worth parsing
because i 100 percent defend what the
president
just said there and i know that's that
some of the things that he said oh there
they make us feel a little squeamish
he's already getting fact checked
they're calling him a liar i i don't
think that he
he said a single lie in that statement
but in in the terms of the facebook fact
checkers it requires
context fine i'm more than happy to give
that context
you know ties in pretty well disrupting
the education space ties in very well
to disrupting the other established
institutions which seem to raid against
president trump right now
what president trump said is that this
is a big fraud being perpetrated on the
american people
that is true he's being fact-checked for
it because they're saying well we don't
know if the election is fraudulent we
don't know if there are fraudulent votes
right now in
pennsylvania or in wisconsin or in
michigan or nevada who knows
that's not the point last night the
election was going for trump the left
had already set the stage for this
because they i guess suspected that
nobody was going to vote
for that daughtering old crook
even though they had the advantage of
early voting and mail-in voting before
before the second presidential debate
before the new york post story showing
the biden family corruption even before
that i think the left thought
gosh maybe we're not going to win this
thing so we need to set the stage we'll
say it's a red mirage trump's going to
win on election night
and then we're going to keep on counting
we're going to keep on counting until we
win
that's the language you heard from joe
biden he said when every vote is counted
then we're going to win you heard this
from josh shapiro the crooked
a.g of pennsylvania obviously deeply
corrupt
man he said when all the votes are
counted biden's going to win how are you
so sure attorney general
do you know something that we don't know
i hope you enjoyed that short segment
from the michael knowles show be sure to
check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts